any really meaningful change is going to
include that day where you feel like
giving up people don't recognize the
fact that every success comes with a lot
of failures and I think we set ourselves
up such that if we meet that obstacle
and fall short that we're not good
enough or that we abandon hope rather
than just recognizing that's part of the
process one of the things I often
encourage people to do who feel like
they don't know what to do when they hit
that kind of setback is to imagine this
is the end of the story and we actually
know the outcome that you have
accomplished this goal or made this
change some point in the future and
you're telling the story of how it
happened I want you to look back at
today and what was the Turning Point how
was this a turning point what was the
next thing you did that moved you in
that story toward change then just do
that basically forecasting your
idealized self and understanding that
what you are stuck in the middle of now
is a part of that Journey